In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium, for July 2, on which we commemorate, the deposition
of the robe of the Most Holy failed occult.
On the 2nd of the month, we celebrate the deposition of the precious robe of our sovereign lady,
the all-holy Mother of God, in the blocker-nate church.
In the time of Emperor Leo I and his wife, Verena, in the years 457-474, two brothers of the
high aristocracy, Galbius and Candidos, having renounced the Aryan heresy, decided to undertake
a pilgrimage to the Holy Land.
When they arrived in Galilee, they found lodgings in the house of an elderly woman, called
Ana, a Jewish by birth, who was devout and virtuous, spending her days and nights in prayer,
in imitation of Ana, the daughter of Fanuel.
Noticing that the Christians would bring Candidos and incense into the inner room of the house
and that a great number of the sick and infirm would spend the night there, the two
pilgrims asked their hostess to explain why this was so.
Ana, bearing witness that the grace of God was working innumerable miracles in the place,
nevertheless told them, at first, that it concerned an ancient Jewish custom handed down
by her ancestors.
As they continued to press her to tell them more, she finally revealed that the robe of the
mother of God was to be found there, and that at the moment of her dormition it had been
given by the all-holy to one of her two Jewish servants, and afterwards passed down from
generation to generation, being always kept secretly by a virgin.
Shedding tears of emotion, Galbius and Candidos asked to spend the whole night in the room so
that they might keep vigil.
Profiting from the sleep of the sick who were present, they secretly took the measurements
of the wooden casket which contained the holy vesture.
In the morning they left for Jerusalem, promising to return on their way home.
Having venerated the sanctuaries of the holy city, they had a similar casket to the one containing
the robe made, and returning to the home of the devout Jewish, found the means to make
off with the casket containing the holy relic, and replace it with the empty box which they
had covered with a rich gold woven cloth.
Arriving in Constantinople, and keeping the whole affair secret, they placed this inestimable
treasure in a place named Blackernay, situated outside the walls in the northwest of the city,
where they had a church built dedicated to the holy apostles, Peter and Mark.
Yet, they were not able to hide this treasure for long as miracles began to be wrought in
the church.
When they revealed to the emperor that they had brought back this precious trophy from their
pilgrimage for the protection of the city, the latter, filled with joy, had a chapel built
to house the casket containing the holy robe, or maphorion, veil of the mother of God.
This casket was later replaced by one, the agus soros, made of gold and silver, and
studied with precious stones.
It is said that the holy robe was woven of a delicate wool, of one color, and in one piece,
and that while the imperial purple in which it had been enveloped, rapidly disintegrated,
the robe remained intact throughout the centuries, thereby clearly manifesting the miracle of
the perpetual virginity of the mother of God.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.